[Music]
my head alright a new study a new study
found that among campus administrators
liberals outnumber conservatives by 12
to 1 knock it off
to put that in perspective North Korea
has more diversity the result is a
student body going deeper into debt and
only exposed to one kind of thinking the
kind that makes kids dumber so they
don't notice it's also making them broke
so let's try some college-level math the
number of college administrators has
doubled in the last 25 years the only
thing growing faster is Jesse's hair and
it's his real hair by the way meanwhile
student debt now tops 1.5 trillion
dollars that's set 37 grand per kid now
what do you get for that a stupidity
farm kept afloat on the backs of
students and their parents and because
they're not learning anything of
practical value it's true students won't
realize this of course 1.5 trillion
dollars it's basically our own Venezuela
a third-world socialist sinkhole
existing within the United States immune
to market forces and common sense and
you and your kids are paying for this
crap if you're 23 you won't be able to
afford a home and you can't get married
until you're done paying for the
provost's new butt lift it's not a bad
thing what a bargain you're getting
poorer and dumber
all for the same price how stupid can
you get go to college and for a mere 37
grand you'll find out
so I think that maybe SMU is a exception
well the message that I'm trying to get
to the college kids standing is that
it's a waste of time
dropout right now and everything will be
great right how about don't listen to
Greg yet but be aware I mean you should
know but your with the cost right the
benefit what is the value that you're
getting what are you paying for and hold
those administrators to get to be fair
SMU is a great school but a lot of these
but Jesse these these kids are gonna be
paying for four years of nothing for the
rest of their lives
yeah I found the father and I'm paying
60 grand for my kid to get brainwashed I
just rather have him watch CNN forward
Churchill the crazy left professor in
Colorado he said people on 9/11 deserve
to die
and it took that university like ten
years the Buddha mouth yes he had tenure
I was just a Cornell asking why is
Cornell so liberally biased and they
kicked me out so it's totally backwards
it's snowflake City they need safe
spaces to do anything anymore if we ever
fight a real war who's gonna fight it
not these guys maybe these guys won you
got to admit 12 to one is groupthink
right oh yeah I think what we need is
affirmative action for academic
underachievers on the right day to go so
disagree with you because I think
parents and students are paying for a
high level education they believe in
education they believe in the benefits
of it and if you go to the books let's
go to the numbers guess what college
graduates make more mm-hmm over time
over their lives yeah yeah but it's not
worth it they're gonna be late buying a
home the late band a second car but they
also will have all the debt that the
baby boomers and Generation X are
putting on them for hey seriously
Gregory yeah rather your kid go to
college or not not if I was like no I
would Peter teal had the great idea
these hundred thousand dollar grants
where you can chart he gets you to open
try to start a business in two years
instead of going to college
I think that's it's better to learn how
to open
business Lawrence yeah so I have some
numbers of myself I cover this every day
of the looser Vincent's camp reform all
right so SMU love you guys love you got
we pulled the FEC reports from SMU over
twenty seventeen to twenty eighteen
eighty five thousand dollars went out
all right
sixty-five thousand of that went to
Democrat organizations financial
financial camping these are the faculty
administrators professors that are on
the college campuses right so if they're
giving toward the Democrats all right
one hundred percent of the donations
sixty five percent of faculty thirteen
thousand of it was the administrators as
well if they're giving to Democrats what
do you think they're teaching the
students yeah I think they'd better be
teaching academics well on one when I
was at Harvard University doing a little
waters world package the other day I
asked these two girls what do you think
about the Fast and Furious scandal and
you know what they said the movie
because meanwhile you're not being
exposed to right-wing conspiracies Oh
San Diego State that that is about
impeaching Donald Trump do we really
want to be teaching our students that
you weren't you don't think it's
important to teach people's around our
democratic process to impeach Donald
Trump I mean that's you can see they're
beautiful but I didn't have to be Donald
Trump
that's just picking on a headline in the
president's not a headline that's an
actual course so I'm saying that's the
headline that's the title of the course
Lawrence but why should our students be
are you are you a snowflake are you
shouldn't be taking the anti-trump
course just like have an hour all you
school for busting kids you're playing
for anti Trump course that's wrong I
don't think Donald Trump yeah yeah
that's it